I mentioned that like oh you know I have
family that or souther and he's look we
don't have cousins that are married do
you and I'm like hi my name is Elizabeth
South I'm a private investigator at Kane
associates investigations here in Los
Angeles California I've been doing this
for probably five or six years and I
have a lot of experience under my belt
everything from surveillances to data
searches background searches infidelity
cases child custody cases major criminal
investigations definitely got my feet
wet in investigations as a bait girl and
as a decoy so basically that means I did
undercover work and I was the liar
today's a different story we are playing
the game two truths and a lie where I
have to figure out which person is not
telling the truth the theme today
horrific first date stories I think it's
gonna be really hard to tell because
here are gotta go really bad first date
stories here in LA my name is Madison
and my worst first date we went to a
smoothie bar at 9:30 in the morning on a
Saturday and he talked the entire time
and tried to pitch me his business idea
to bring to BuzzFeed that actually
happened that's terrible and I'm sorry
so my name is Jasmine and my first date
horror story is that during casual
conversation with my date Hite came up I
think I was saying something like oh I
wish I was taller you know for models
usually I'm like 511 plus and he said
well it could be worse
you could be a [ __ ] haha that would
suck I mean what'd it feel like your
sister was a [ __ ] or something and
then you're like well really right you
never know who's mentioned that like oh
you know I have family that or souther
and he's look we don't have cousins that
are married do you and I'm like oh he's
a charmer hi my name is Nadia my first
date horror story is that I accidentally
took an edible prior to the first date
thinking it was just a cookie
and back in heaven yeah no all right so
this happened around 9:00 in the morning
was this recent yeah it happened about
three months ago oh my god how'd you
guys meet so we actually met at this
like singles wine party event that one
of my friends threw and he was there and
I was leaving he asked me for my
Instagram which I thought was a little
weird cuz like he's a little bit older
than me and I figured he would like want
my phone number maybe but yeah he asked
for my Instagram and would like DM me
for weeks I asked you on a date this
morning date at a smoothie bar which is
a strange first day I thought it was a
little strange too but I was kind of
into it I was like oh like maybe he's up
early and maybe he likes fitness I'm
like okay like I can deal with it but
that shouldn't be my first red flag
alright so you're not gonna see him
again no I didn't see him again when you
were at this party why did you give him
your Instagram handle so it was like a
singles party so there was a bunch of
single people there and he just was like
the cutest one unfortunately that's
about where it ends up yeah questions
for you where do you mean it well I
actually do practice dates with guys who
are socially awkward like before but
yeah the company hires me and other
girls to go on dates with these guys and
it kind of educates them on what to do
and what not to do so he was my first
date for that night but kind of rotate
between five guys that sounds kind of
weird go girl so he was one of the guys
that was my practice date I guess or
more I was his practice date and I was
definitely a let's write this on the
survey as don't do this you actually had
a human survey basically right what they
did good what they did bad so they
actually had feedback on what to do next
time we're not to do next time did you
meet anybody know you liked yeah there
was a really nice British guy there's an
option at the end of the survey where
would you be interested in dating this
guy and you see if the guy asked for you
to maybe that guy went on that bad date
with ask for you and just don't know it
they'll let you know ahead of time like
if someone's interested would you be
interested in going on a return date
then they'll swap contact information
but it's not like you find out right
away then I go on to you hi okay when
did this happen five years ago I was
visiting some friends in San Francisco
and I had tinder so I matched it with a
cutie we just really like chatting a
little bit and she's like hey I'm gonna
be getting some dinner at this place do
you wanna come with me I was like yes I
was hanging out with my friend I was
like hey I really want to go and meet up
with this cutie and as I cool and
she had these cookies and I didn't know
that they were edibles it's like I just
kind of grabbed one like what I do where
would these are they're just like on the
counter on it like a plate I don't eat
it I just popped it in I was like these
tastes really weird oh no no no no no
those are my edibles I was like what
[Laughter]
before yes I only took a bite that last
time so I figured because the cookies
were so small it would be okay no
they're important they're very very
important and how did you find your way
there did you follow the cavern we had
talked about it man my friend that I was
staying with and I was like I can just
walk this is that oh it's really
straightforward you didn't know how like
you like that sounds very
straightforward to me yeah and so I
start walking and then they started
actually like feeling the effects of the
cookie I got like a little bit of like
auditory hallucinations while I was
walking thick is it okay I get to the
restaurant and no I'm not feeling okay
I'm like I don't know but luckily she
spotted me right away all I could
remember was act normal it felt like it
took an hour for the waitress to come
through it was one of those things where
like we weren't that homey but we wanted
to share a plate so we're sitting there
and I was like trying to act normal what
you're not is the worst right now the
waitress comes by puts down to like
full-size plate and I kind of like I
look at it and then it just all comes
out all on the table I'm in the bowl and
the bowl caught it so then to the waiter
come clean it up and I covered the bull
the waitress comes through to ask you
how's the food and the person sitting
across from you just okay with you
covering the bowl and sitting there no
she was like are you okay like what's
going on like are you feeling okay and I
said I accidentally got too high before
I came here and it was all a mistake so
the waitress came through and I said hey
I had an accident and she like couldn't
look at it and she said oh sweet and
understanding I was like are you serious
thank you so you should like scooped it
up and she took it out we waited for the
cheque to come and he said yo I should
just go your story is very easy to go
through I felt like your emotion was
real and I felt like you were actually
pretty disappointed that the guy was so
cute and then he took you to a smoothie
place and it just you know you thought
he's gonna be healthy and everything
however he could be just giving me a
story
you're just really good at telling some
story you made up I don't know yours I
was kind of iffy and you're the one I'm
like I don't know maybe I should believe
her maybe I shouldn't she seems like
she's got a good tongue on her for
telling a tale so yours a kind of
question a little bit but I feel like
you might have something to do with
actually dating situations like this
because that heart felt real to me and
you not much of yours feels real to me
no okay no the story could totally be
real but I've never seen anybody puke in
a contained fashion and I've never heard
of like just sitting there and I'm not
trying to move you out right away and
bring somebody over to clean more things
stuff like they would have been wiping
off the table and doing a lot of other
things so that for me brings you out as
the person who's not telling the truth
on my best gesture you know you if I
fail this I'm going to feel really bad
right now
I might regret this but I think you were
telling me the truth yours was if he's
so I'm gonna go with you as the lie and
these is the two truths
you know why okay I'm gonna tell you
what this is John was measuring me up
that way to get any of the other wine
but the only thing that gave yours away
really was the puking in the bowl but
that was the only thing that was true
quiet it was quiet
it was very contained I like ever seen
that and this straight through is the
exact thing I don't know how we got
there cuz like we just equip we're right
so you know they're not straight through
[Music]